[Music]
and today it comes out navient uh this
from the new york times reaches a 1.85
billion dollar deal
to settle claims of predatory
behavior
that's a lot of money 1.85 billion
hey it's really important that we note
dave
they didn't do anything wrong yeah
yeah that's that's what's this is one of
the largest settlements i've ever seen
in my life of anything the government is
sued
government sues somebody they usually
get a little money for the people
they're suing on behalf of
uh
1.85
billion
dollars and uh
mark helene naviance chief legal officer
who's about as full of crap as anybody
i've ever read
quote was the company decision to
resolve these matters which were based
on unfounded claims allows us to avoid
the additional burden expense time and
distraction to prevail in court
honey you don't give up 1.85 billion
with a b if you think there's a
snowball's chance you're going to
prevail in court
you might give up 100 million
but not 1.85
billion
that's a billion is a thousand million
that's 1800 000 million oh my gosh
eighteen hundred million i took a day
off of work to go sit in court over a
two hundred dollar ticket one time that
i thought i was right on one point eight
billion dollars no it was somebody else
it was it was other kids now the other
kids naviate which did not admit any
fault in the settlement said it did not
act illegally
of course you acted illegally you don't
give up 1.85 billion just predators in
your settlement if you didn't do that
now here's how here's how wild these
figures are okay now to date uh these
numbers are a little bit old so i will i
will take a pass on this but on my
little cheat sheet here
to date just under 4 000 borrowers
200 250 000 people have applied
for private student loan forgiveness
okay under the 10-year
private student loan forgiveness plan
okay
4 000 people out of the 250 000 were
actually granted the forgiveness yeah at
an average of 87 000 a piece
so
here's the irony of this okay the entire
private student loan forgiveness program
has now forgiven
way less than navient
that little sally may thing that thing
they had in maui where they all had a
little getaway to celebrate how many
people they'd screwed that that really
didn't come up oh wow
yeah so the deal announced thursday
requires navient to cancel 1.7 billion
in private student loans which is about
4x what the entire private student loan
forgiveness program has ever done and
they had a little bit of a little bitty
fine of another 100 million dollars yeah
95 million in restitution but they
didn't do anything wrong that's right
they're just
it's just
1.7 billion in forgiven loans that means
they were proven to have screwed those
people yeah taking advantage of people
that didn't know what they were doing
this is a black black business we are in
people
this whole student loan thing
and if you lefties you want to keep
talking about giving forgiving student
loans and the biden administration is
going to forgive student loans and all
that that's great
before you actually enter that
discussion with integrity though you
have to stop making them
yeah what's the plan there that's like
saying hey sheila though you're asking
me oh i'm just thinking like was that a
rhetorical question okay hey john the
house kind of generally at the universe
what's the plan yeah we're not there i
don't understand it because we're going
to keep making them so that there's more
people we're going to forgive them
january one and then all these students
will enroll the next semester and
keep i did see this i saw this data
point today one million fewer college
students are enrolled this semester
well i mean the lowest in 50 years let
me tell you what's happening big time i
mean this yale lawsuit came up this week
too where there's about 10 or 15 of
these uh yale mit brown they're all sued
for using for colluding on their prices
so higher ed's getting another black eye
especially the famous college right the
muckety mucks right they're getting
another black eye on screwing their
their own people over their own students
over but you got a million people saying
i'm going to study online i'm going to
stay at home i'm just going to get a job
what do you think about it i mean the
guy called up here the day from michigan
state and said uh he goes
i just signed up for all my classes and
then they canceled them all and said
they're all online and he goes i want my
money back well yeah i'll go to work for
college cancel them yeah and go if
you're gonna take online don't pay
you know all that price for that
absolutely cancel them all get your
money back and that's what's happening
these guys have forgotten that they are
in the business of serving the student
um
arrogant yeah beyond belief and we're
just gonna cover to shut it down and
we're to charge you anyway so although
the students are going i don't think so
i think i'm just not going to come let's
try that a consultant came and spoke to
us you may have even heard this story
before
um came and talked to us at university i
worked at once and
said that um told us it was a parable of
some sort about
a drill bit company that was selling
drill bits and had a record drill bit
year and the the ceo was talking about
how many drill bits they'd sold and
they'd sold a bunch of drill bits and
they were heroes
and then the president got up and
quietly said
i want us never forget we're not in the
drill bit business we're in the hole
making business and somebody's gonna go
make a hole cheaper and faster and
better than us than our drill bits we
better be careful and higher education
has to realize we're in the education
business
not in the making ourselves look bigger
and better business well not making
ourselves look like we are covet
politically correct
whatever we're all worried about all
worried about the audience absolutely
it's politically correct
maybe you ought to be teaching somebody
something i don't know there's an idea
this is the ramsay show